hi in this video I'm going to solve
another cushion from IT jam and it's on
NMR so let's see what this question
asked so this question asks among the
following compounds which of these will
show to singlets so we have to find the
compounds which would give two picks and
both pixar singlet peaks in their proton
NMR spectrum so so there are four
compounds and I've drawn the structure
for all the four compounds first one is
one for dichlorobenzene so you can see
this is a benzene ring this is one and
this is for position there are two
chlorines now we have to analyze how
many type of how many picks would be
there and whether these Peaks are
singlet or not let's see so actually we
have for gaining the idea about how many
peak there would be we have to figure
out how many chemically different
hydrogen's are there and the number of
chemically different hydrogen's would be
the number of Peaks so for this
particular molecule the hydrogen present
here and hydrogen present here have the
same chemical environment so for these
and for this we would get earth peak so
this let's merge in it as a peak then
for this point this point and these two
points for all these points we would get
another type of peak it's B type of peak
so for the for this particular thing we
would get two peaks in its NMR spectrum
so two peaks would be there and now we
have to judge whether these Peaks are
singlet or doublet or whatever so for
this particular compound we have the
molecular environment of these two
hydrogen's are similar so they would on
one type of hydrate one one peak and the
molecular environment of these two
hydrogen's are same and these two
hydrogen's are same so total three Peaks
would be there so the three singlets
Peaks would be there
and so this could not be our option
because we have to find two picks and
towards singlet let's see here so here
we have a hydrogen which is attached a
hydrogen which is attached to a carbon
and the carbon is further attached to
the oxygen and here the carbon with the
hydrogen's are attached to a carbon so
here and here there there are two
different chemical environments so here
is a type 1 proton and type 2 proton so
there would be two peaks there would be
two peaks over here and for this
compound also the hydrogen over here and
the hydrogen over here have a same
molecular environment safe electronic
environment I would say and then for
this point it has our different
environment so still here we would get
two peaks so for this question three of
our options are showing that they have
two picks now we have to judge whether
these Peaks are singlet doublet or
triplet let's see so for this thing we
would use the n plus one rule so that
just to remind the N plus rule so for
this proton if we want to see that
whether the Pyxis singlet or tablet to
this corresponding to this a proton we
have to check with their carbon and the
hydrogen that are associated with its
neighbor carbon so this carbon is not
attached to any carbon and any hydrogen
is not present with its neighbor
so in our n plus one rule here in would
be zero and it would be one that means
it is singlet it is singlet so we just
have to look so we have this hydrogen
attached with this carbon we have to
look for its nearest neighbor its
nearest neighbor is oxygen and we have
to look whether these oxygen is linked
to any hydrogen or not so the number of
hydrogen attached to this neighbor is n
so here n is zero so we put zero and one
plus one that's our rule states so it's
total 1 that means it's a single peak
for similarly
if we put n plus 1 rule for this thing
for these B type hydrogen there is
oxygen over here in the surrounding over
here we have oxygen so and if in any way
it has no proton with its neighbor so
it's n plus 1 equal to 0 plus 1 here so
it would be one pick of one peak and
singlet peak and for these hydrogen also
its neighbor is oxygen no hydrogen
attached to its nearest neighbor
so it would be single at peak and let's
see about these things so for if we talk
about these a type hydrogen and want to
see with whether these peak
corresponding to a type hydrogen is
singlet or doublet we would see that
with a type hydrogen it has a neighbor B
when when in the beep or type hydrogen
in being the B type hydrogen there are
actually 1 hydrogen so here n plus 1
would be n plus 1 equal to 1 plus 1
actually 2 so here the peak would be
doublet instead of a single peak we
would get a doublet peak for these
particular things so here are definitely
two peaks but two picks are doublet not
singlet so correct this is the msq
question so correct options would be
this one and correct option will be this
one so C and B are the correct option
for these mcq question I hope you
enjoyed this video don't forget to give
it a quick thumbs up please subscribe
thank you